now Avatar still stands as the highest
grossing movie of all time and with the
release of its sequel I thought I'd do a
deep dive on the original to point out
the hidden details Easter eggs and
things you might miss in it throughout
this video I want to go through 23 of
the best things in the film to point out
some great attention to detail in it the
movie's been out since 2009 and these
are some things I've noticed over the
years read online and been told by
people over the almost decade and a half
since it first dropped I've tried to
credit people where I could but huge
apologies if I forgot your name from the
the thing that you told me back in 2013.
I'll never forget the times we had
together though and if you enjoy the
video it helps us out massively if you
hit the thumbs up button and don't
forget to subscribe for videos like this
every day by the way thank you for
clicking this now let's get into our
Avatar breakdown
foreign
who ends up becoming an avatar after the
death of his twin brother his brother
was part of the program which created
avatars so that humans could roam the
planet of Pandora using host bodies in
order to create this link though human
DNA had to be embedded into the hosts in
order to make it so they are lined
enough with their driver so that they
wouldn't cause issues humans are of
course used to doing things with four
fingers and we can see that all the
avatars carry four fingers and a thumb
on each hand now throughout the movie
Jake and a teary get closer and closer
and we actually see a four finger mark
on her later on in the movie when the
theory has her warpaint on we can see
that she has a handprint on her chest it
says four fingers on it showing that
Jake helped to apply it now another
thing that you might not have noticed is
that all of the human avatars also have
eyebrows the native Navi however don't
and this is a more subtle detail to set
them apart as speaking of body hair we
also subtly see the passage of time
through Jake's hair growth throughout
the entire film in the opening of the
extended cat he has long hair which is
then cut short once he becomes drafted
Jake gets a buzz cut and later on the
sides of this end up growing out
eventually he has a full head of their
care at the end of the movie and this
happens before he gets transferred into
the navi body a huge shout out to Philip
Lipton shoot on Reddit for pointing out
that 99 of the animals on Pandora have
six limbs whereas the navi just have
four similar to humanity they evolved to
walk upright and much like how he gain
the posable thumbs they gained shoulders
whether there is something beyond that
and in the trees we see lima-like
creatures swinging which have two these
are actually The Missing Link and the
stage between the other animals of the
planet the upright Navi who climbed
trees and walk in a bipedal stance now
for the thanatore they actually reuse
the Roar of the T-Rex from the Jurassic
Park movies which is a nice little nod
to that movie
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
to Jurassic Park the dire horses also
make the same noises that the Raptors do
I don't know if this was just a lazy
sound designer or if James Cameron
really likes that movie but those two
things popping up it seems like it's
more than a coincidence now the movie
sees the navi going up against the
forces of Colonel quadrich James Cameron
is often inserted metaphors for the US
military into his work and the soldiers
we follow in Aliens were deliberately
meant to look like how the US dressed
during the Vietnam war the Xenomorphs
were very much the indigenous species
with the us trying to make the planet
theirs this is the same in the case of
Avatar and Cameron subtly embeds the
Stars and Stripes flag into the
environment early on when Jake meets a
colonel for the first time we can see
him giving a meeting and behind him
there are several stripe blinds these
are spaced apart evenly and in the top
left-hand Corner we can also see a box
this layout makes it represent the flag
and nurse when we meet the colonel he's
an embodiment of the US the dog get
annoyed at me for being British here I
hire Jared and Cameron says the message
of the film is more the whole nature
thing rather than him being against the
military but this could be echoing
movies like Patton to show how he
symbolizes the nation now the hints that
Jake is in the Marines happens when we
see him climbing vines to tame the
mountain banshees he uses something
called the S method which is taught in
Marine boot camp as a way to quickly
Traverse ropes and Vines Now in a more
positive nod-2 U.S institution we also
see that Sigourney Weaver's Grace wears
a Stanford top when we first meet her
Sigourney actually graduated from
Stanford back in the 70s and this is a
nice nut to her pass she also smokes at
several points throughout the movie and
according to the making of this
cigarette was actually CGI a CGI goret
if you will
now instead she used a toothpick as a
stand-in and this was meant to show how
she didn't really care about her health
in her actual body just her health and
her Avatar she also drops this line
don't play with that you'll go blind now
this is pretty much the of the navi and
it's what we see Jake and itiri using
later to get it on in case there's any
kids watching this ask your parents what
it means about him going blind from
playing with it too much and a nice
little detail from Jimmy C there now
they head out with Norm who's also part
of the program as well we can catch him
wearing cap with dots on it and it turns
out that these are actually Braille when
put into a braille translator these read
1969 which was of course the heir of the
first moon landing now other cool
details of that Trudy ship is actually
referred to as Rogue one I did at first
think this might be a Star Wars
reference but as that movie didn't come
out until 2016 it doesn't seem likely I
racked my brains to think if it had been
used before in Star Wars but I'm pretty
sure Rogue one was the first time that
it popped up in the universe so
therefore I think she's simply referring
to the fact that she went wrong from her
initial Mission and is now fighting with
the navi Jake is captured and he's taken
prisoner but rather than locking his
hands together like how they would on
Earth they'd grab him by his ponytail
this is in order to bind him and and
it's basically the equivalent of
grabbing it on Earth in order to take in
a prison which well we'll not go into
that now Grace ends up teaching the navi
kids through using the book The Lorax
this actually plays into the themes of
the movie and in case you haven't read
it the Dr Seuss story is very much a
cautionary tale it teaches respect for
the environment and animals and the idea
of preservation so that future
Generations can Thrive the movie is very
much about embracing nature of
industrialization and the planet of
Pandora is a paradise that's rich in a
mineral called an obtainium pretty
stupid name but Cameron didn't actually
make it up the word itself originates
from the 1950s where it was used by
aerospace engineers to refer to a
material that was either very costly or
impossible to get a hold of it's a term
that tends to be used widely across the
board in Aerospace when Engineers are
coming up with names to call things that
need to be able to withstand re-entry
the heat caused by this can melt those
metals and thus the idea that there's
something like this has been used for
that purpose a huge elastic Colossus 13
for pointing out the Pandora and the
planet also has ties to mythology
Pandora orbits a gas planet called
polythemus which has massive storms
around its aqueda in the same way that
the eye of Jupiter does this having one
eye means that it's referred to as a
cyclops and polythemus was a cyclops in
Greek mythology Pandora orbiting it
seems like an eye and thus this is why
the gas giant gets call that too at the
end Jake ends up becoming one with his
Avatar and his Consciousness is
transferred into it which will take us
into Avatar too however depending on
what version you watch the opening shot
actually foreshadows descending now the
extended edition opens with shots of a
rainforest however the theatrical cut
has Jake in his blue tank which we get
later on in the Extended Cut this shot
has him basked in a blue light somewhat
foreshadowing the transfer of him into a
blue body now the movie also carries the
idea that death brings new life with it
and this is of course seen throughout
the film Jake's brother's death gives
him the opportunity to have a new life
on Pandora and the death of his body at
the end also allows him to become a Nabi
the home tree is also burned as well and
the death of this starts off a new life
for the characters to move on to just
like how Jake's brother was cremated the
tree is burned too but From the Ashes
rise up something more powerful its
details like this that are at the heart
of the movie and it's what helps Avatar
become more than just a roller coaster
ride that closes out the film which I've
enjoyed going back to the return to
Pandora for me was an enjoyable one and
I can't wait to see what other details
we unearth in the upcoming sequel as of
making this video yet I haven't seen it
but if you have then let me know your
thoughts in it below also if there's any
details we missed then make sure you
drop them in the comments section we are
running a competition right now giving
away three copies of House of the dragon
on the 15th of December and all you have
to do to be on the chance of winning is
like the video make sure you subscribe
to notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the film if
you pick the comments out random and the
winners of the last one are on screen
right now save that to you then message
me on Twitter at heavy spoilers if you
want something else to watch then make
sure you check out one of our breakdowns
linked on screen right now you just
don't want the interstellar that goes
really in depth so if you had fun with
this one then definitely head over there
right after this by the way thanks for
sticking through the video I've been
poor I'll see you next time take care
peace